the fbi is investigating the discovery
of a noose in the garage
of nascar's only african-american driver
it is believed to be part of the fallout
from the organization's recent ban
of confederate symbols which is a
growing movement throughout the country
correspondent kevin cork has details
it was a powerful symbol solidarity and
unwavering fidelity for both sport
and driver it was all in support of
nascar driver bubba wallace
the sport's lone african-american driver
whose garage
was the scene of an apparent despicable
act on sunday
a noose discovered near his team garage
a warning or perhaps
a reminder of a violent and forgettable
past etched into america's fabric
that noose was found by a member of his
team just hours after someone
blew a confederate flag over alabama's
talladega super speedway
to protest nascar banning the symbol at
all events
and while views on the flag issue are
mixed among nascar fans
support for wallace in the wake of the
noose incident was resounding
richard petty seven-time nascar champion
affectionately known as the king
said there's absolutely no place in our
sport or society for racism
adding this filthy act serves as a
reminder of how far we still have to go
lebron james tweeted his support to
wallace i just want to continue to say
how proud i am of you
for continuing to take a stand for
change here in america
and sports wallace has created some
controversy with nascar fans
thanks to his vocal support of the black
lives matter movement and to be clear
while both nascar and the fbi are
investigating this incident
there's still much we don't know about
what's alleged to have happened
including what did surveillance cameras
capture and who had access or
opportunity
it's all part of an increasingly
complicated portrait
of a country re-examining its past and
pondering its future
and nowhere is that more evident than
outside the american museum of natural
history in new york
where a statue of former president teddy
roosevelt is now in queue to be removed
over concerns of its reflection of
racism and imperialism
and right there was this from dale
earnhardt jr on twitter he said i hope
bubba
is feeling loved and supported keep
sending him that love and support
he needs it now more than ever brett
kevin thank you